welcome to this video this is the
coverage for the final round of the
candidates tournament and this is about
the game of our tournament winner former
champion Vijay Anand against Peter
Svidler yeah while still ahead and sort
of rule across the tournament some good
games some they are not some awful games
there he had one really awful game
against Apollo he had had blunders he
had good ideas it was a really really
weird tournament for him while of course
for vitiates
just yeah just an outstanding result he
pretty much did what no one expected
it's going to happen that he basically
earns a return match the the old term
right of the return match sort of is
it's coming back here with Russia this
time having earned his right to to get
this this chance to get the tile back ok
let's have a look at this game um Villa
is on a -1 score he really
I guess does not want to do anything
special in this game just play a solid
good game and see what's going to happen
well I'm not already am yeah he can try
a bit but I mean he certainly is not
very much keen on not losing the game
this party he could actually afford to
do so but it's always we had to sort of
lose when you already have won the
tournament
so because I'm willow past spanish
opening and this also is a change for
Sevilla he lost this very yeah this very
awful game with black against the
parliament Sicilian and he switched back
to the double King pawn now which is not
something out of the ordinary Sweden has
played one e45 for for a long time he
had played various lines and in the in
the Roy
even the the classical lines like
after this like with d6 he had played
this the Brier all kinds of lights but
he always was a practitioner of them of
the martial attack of course and yeah
with both sides he has played it and
down and of course as well so huge
expert and now our nerd will see three
is actually allowing the Marshall which
shows in a way that he wants to play it
safe it's always a bit of a weird logic
that allowing this sharp opening is the
safer choice but it's simply the case
that with let's say d3 or h3 this can of
lines you
sd3 actually move here just just
wondering yeah why not actually could
you could do that when h3 is the most
common and time marshal nowadays um yeah
this is leading more to a full game
let's say with all pieces on the board
and this was actually the choice of
honored in the first round when he won
this very crucial game against Aronian
yeah c3 now we get some theoretical news
of course here white has the choice d3
or deform I'm not an expert on the
marshal I Muslims warn you what I did is
I I try to get us at least a rough
overview um what what is going how's
this game let's say relates to the
latest theory so I can point you to some
things but it's not like I'm a big
expert on the opening I've played this
the black side of the way for years but
I never played the marshal it just
seemed too much memorization to me um
well c6
um yeah d3 play d4 is the principle
alternative Bishop d6 Ruby 1 and in this
position for me are not being an expert
the move Queen h4 looks like the most
natural to me but when I was checking
the the database and the game history it
turned out that this move was actually
completely out of fashion it seems to
have fallen off the map basically in a
top-level chess it's probably something
like that is the reason for it but okay
I don't want to tell anything that is
maybe maybe even wrong because I don't
know it precisely why this is out of
fashion but it's not played anymore on
high level chests they all play a Bishop
to f5 not that this is an illogical move
I'm just saying that it cannot really
determine why Queen h4 si is bad queen a
free plate yeah of course just attacking
this why not very sensible move and in
this position black also has a choice um
Queen H form is awesome and in fact was
played only recently in the game karana
Aronian in this zurich tournament um
Derek continued with the g3 Queen h3 and
then white relatively quickly gave back
the pawn just with this Bishop here 92
oops 92 and what got quite a good
development and later had a slightly
better endgame that he managed to win
against them Aronian in this game
however stood less playing a difference
he plays a Queen to f6 which also has
been played a number of times before
it's not exactly a normal team um yeah
what are not no place is also not new
but a rare movie plays Bishop d2 a move
that sometimes no some more times has
been seen before this Bishop takes d5 a
very obvious move why just tries to grab
this pawn let's look at this if white
takes him yeah ken white actually take
even this pawn
yeah I'm not sure that it is some is a
direct mistake but people have not dared
to do that but some it looks very
awkward with white being completely and
underdeveloped maybe black is just
trying to do something like that
completely centralizing everything young
and there are ideas still Queen h4 queen
g6 yeah black certainly has a good
compensation what was tried in
high-level chest before it's the move
Bishop f4 in this position which looks
perfectly logical black now takes and
plays d4 this is a very important point
that was first shown in the game Judit
Polgar against Aronian again he's huge
expert on the marshal of course and this
ended in a draw rather rather quickly
after takes root d8 black is getting his
pawn back one of the two pawns and it's
so active that it's a very decent
equality yeah well then this didn't
happen I'll click 92 which also makes
lots of sense of course trying to get
this reform yeah it was answered by
Queen to g6
and now of course nighty Forum is
hanging the Queen basically and in fact
this move is quite a threat white needs
to react to that if you try to do this
to prevent Bishop before you need to
have something ready against Knight f4
and I don't think that this looks too
comfortable on our plate the move Bishop
to d1 which looks really awkward so sure
again putting a piece on the background
but the idea is just to go ninety form
yeah and this in fact would pretty much
stop all black play so black is
basically forced to take on d3 if you
look at the move let's say here yeah
just for example white is putting this
not only for
and it's not clear what black blacks
next movers you don't really have
anything great in store and white maybe
just plays Bishop d2 and slowly unravels
it still feels like black handsome
conversation but yeah it's it's not
clear if this should why should this be
any better than taking the d3 porn this
is what's Villa did he took it and now
Knight to e4 yeah this is this shows why
it's idea this is now basically trapped
so needed to take Queen takes and we got
these trades and so what happened white
has returned the pawn but in the process
has gained are the two bishops which
admittedly are not very active at the
moment and black is very nicely
developed he however has somewhat loose
Queen side so it's not yet clear who is
benefiting him rook e8 yeah this is just
speeding up development white really
does not have much else than taking it
takes takes and King f1 was played yeah
quite funny is that this had been played
before all this had been played before
in a game in 2013
between kawana white they these guys
play a lot of those openings Kawana
white against Muslim cousin John of
black ok Kasim Jon off ok
he's if I'm not mistaken he's one of on
on seconds still I guess Kasim Jonna was
still part of Allen's team and I think
he also has worked with fiddler times so
yeah those guys know what's going on
okay Bishop f4 is the new move by a
Swede lie instead of the move Bishop e5
one that was played by Kasim John of in
the mentioned game this has the idea to
play before Bishop f4 ever even looks
more straightforward to me trying to get
the bishop pair off the board
Bishop a3 plate takes takes and King f8
yeah we have a very simplified position
now that I think should be somewhere
between a very very minimal edge for
white and and equal here a3 was played
and in fact funny enough only this is a
new move there is a game shear off
against the finish Grandmaster to mean I
back one new back where she referred
played b3 but they agreed a draw
soon afterwards this was played even in
2014 so there's nothing new Under the
Sun yeah III played um yeah what else is
there I mean what what can why try the
only real idea left is C form to trying
to get at the c64 maybe if you go c4
immediately there's night before and
this is some leading to absolutely
nothing probably this is just what Alan
wanted to prepare a three rope t8 no c4
and now nigh therefore this is a Swede
let's count to play the night is coming
to d3 it looks a bit hairy at the moment
this is this is all a bit weak but after
the capture night to d3 and this it
turns out that beach was just good
enough to to build up how to play
against you just took it here to convey
- yeah and now black with this very
important pinning operation is
completely equalizing things you had
this trade in and now even the pawns
went so after 34 Museum both players
agreed on a draw not a very big surprise
that this game isn't the most exciting
encounter in this tournament as well as
certainly not I mean what what should he
do we are trying to play the the Latvian
gambit and score win
no he isn't he just plays a normal game
and if nothing materialized the draw is
perfectly okay well for Vichy I mean
he's won this tournament it's a big
triumph ready for him and okay if Sula
would have done something we had out of
his preparation the she certainly was
ready to exploit it but yeah my draw is
perfectly fine what Elsa can yeah I mean
he has achieved everything he could
dream of in this event and no reason to
do anything to do anything fancy here
alright yeah maybe some detail about the
Marshall attack could could interest you
other than that I understand that this
is very much somewhat somewhat
computerized type of game it's lots of
preparation involved and this type of
game where you have the first new move
on move what is it 24 right 24 and we
already here in a in a reduced material
state with an probably around equalent
game this type of game is the the reason
why very often nowadays players on those
high levels and try to vary their
openings and play sometimes those kind
of timid looking flank openings so it's
not a 3G 3 B 3 this kind of stuff that
often looks very young yeah looks a bit
boring at first sight I mean I'm playing
these openings myself as white but my
experience is that while you get some
boring games that's true but if both
players really want to want to fight you
will quite often get interesting games
and it it's very often a case of keeping
material on the board and just delaying
the crisis of the game to a later stage
in some of those outwardly more sharp
openings like sharper openings like the
Marshall you at this level at least very
often get this kind of yeah
preparation walls where they have these
little wrinkles prepared and you don't
really get a real game and this is why
very often in the decisive games people
switch to two other other setups let's
say kayaking in the game yesterday when
he had ride against against honored he
soared and it didn't want sort of the
Verdun endgame or some kind of prep and
in the line and went for Knight f3 d4
III this kind of slow approach and he
got got a game going at least and put on
a long depression alright I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this game even
though it was a very brief one thanks
for watching